tonight las vegas expressing their  thoughts on tomorrow's big election day  while thousands have already voted  it seems more and more people are  thinking about what will happen after  the votes are all counted  some do have concerns about unrest but  overall everyone is just looking for  a unified front no matter who wins the  presidency  last election some people protested and  there was some damage  we say riots because they didn't get  their way and then  with what's happened previously with the  looting and rioting  maybe but i'm not too concerned about it  i don't want to think about the  president every single day of my life  all day long i kind of want to have my  own  life and my own time with my dog and you  know i want things to kind of be  more normal we should all  work together we are so divided  and we should be united